sais pas c'est l'heure de notre seconde
débat évidemment consacré alors ce soir
je vous propose de parler de la crise du
logement des taux d'intérêt élevés des
ventes en baisse moins de construction
neuve à mon client de HLM les
difficultés sont multiples notamment
dans les grandes villes un exemple à
Paris ou pour recruter des soignants la
PHP les hôpitaux de Paris propose des
logements sociaux grâce à des aides de
l'État et de la municipalité Marion
ligre
depuis un an marine peut prendre le
temps de petits déjeuner sans craindre
d'être en retard au travail
l'appartement de la PHP qu'elle a obtenu
offre deux avantages la proximité de
l'hôpital où elle est employée et un
loyer très abordable pour le marché
parisien je paye 900 euros pour 50
mètres carrés et avant je payais 1000
euros pour 38 mètres carrés soit 18
euros le mètre carré quand le prix moyen
à Paris est de 32 euros une économie non
négligeable pour cette jeune kiné
rémunéré 2000 euros brut par mois mais
aussi un gain en qualité de vie
conséquence quitté Paris peut encore
attendre le loyer qui est moins cher le
fait qu'on soit qu'on nous propose des
logements juste à côté du boulot ça me
permet en fait de faire plus d'activité
de plus sortir de profiter à plus de la
vie parisienne comme on dit ça permet de
se dire j'ai envie de rester à Paris
pour l'instant profitez de mon logement
profiter du boulot améliorer les
conditions de vie et de travail de ses
soignants voici l'objectif que se fixe
la PHP en 4 ans le groupe des hôpitaux
de Paris a perdu 11 de ses infirmiers il
lui faut donc redevenir attractif et le
logement de ces personnels devient une
priorité le groupe veut doubler ses
capacités en passant de 600 logements
attribués chaque année à 1200 jusque-là
on arrivait à répondre à environ 25 27 %
de la demande annuelle notre objectif
c'est de réussir à répondre à 40 à 50%
de la demande pour y parvenir le groupe
mobilise son fonciers sont parc
immobilier mais peut aussi compter sur
l'aide de l'État l'agence régionale de
santé d'Île-de-France a ainsi débloqué
l'an dernier 50 millions d'euros pour
aider les hôpitaux allogés leurs
soignants autre objectif du groupe mieux
cibler les bénéficiaires une offre de
logements sociaux pour nos agents qui
correspondent aux critères du logement
social voilà on a une offre plus récente
qui est à destination des métiers dit en
tension à l'hôpital donc c'est par
exemple les infirmiers les infirmiers
spécialisés les manipulateurs radio ou
encore les sages-femmes par exemple donc
là c'est une offre avec un niveau de
loyer qui est un petit peu supérieur à
celui du logement social mais qui reste
très inférieur à celui du marché dit
libre donc ça reste quand même très
attractif et la plupart du temps c'est
d'en parler ou en petite couronne donc
c'est des localisations qui sont
attractives aussi et puis la troisième
offre elle est encore plus spécifique et
pour les jeunes pro qui sortent de
l'école et une politique que soutient la
ville de Paris en y mettant néanmoins un
bémol celui de ne pas empiéter sur le
parc de logements sociaux réservé au
plus précaires et à comme un travail à
faire de d'un nouveau modèle pour
réfléchir mais qui ne doit pas remplacer
le logement social qui doit continuer à
être attribué en fonction évidemment des
revenus il faut arriver à avoir des
modèles complémentaires des logements
sociaux très sociaux intermédiaires et
des logements de fonction qui doivent
s'articuler avec l'aide de l'État avec
aussi l'aide de la PHP vous savez la PHP
a quand même un parc immobilier
important un parc de 9300 appartements
auxquels s'ajoutent désormais 400
nouveaux logements cédés par la ville de
Paris
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce second débat de sens
public Ingrid nappy bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes économie spécialiste des
questions immobilières et professeurs à
l'école des pompes Paris Tech Max
Brisson bonsoir bonsoir sénateur LR les
républicains des Pyrénées-Atlantiques
christophe Robert bonsoir bienvenue à
vous si vous êtes délégué général de la
Fondation Abbé Pierre Mathieu croissanto
est resté évidemment à mes côtés on
commence par le constat qui est Ingrid
nappy le constat d'une multicrise c'est
à dire que on a l'impression que ça
touche un peu tous les secteurs du du
logement l'immobilier est-ce que c'est
est-ce que je vois peut-être lever les
yeux au ciel c'est pas si vrai non non
je dis qu'on est toujours en crise en
fait depuis les la baisse des taux
d'intérêt comme la remontée des taux
d'intérêts on ne parle toujours que de
crise je pense qu'on peut parler de
crise du logement parce que on n'a pas
un type de logement on n'a pas un marché
du logement le logement il est multiple
alors un des indicateurs pour mesurer
cette crise du logement qui peut être à
la fois qualitative comme quantitative
c'est le fameux taux d'effort des
ménages pour dépenser pour présenter
exactement sur la dépense logement dans
le dans leur budget et on était à peu
près en 1960 à 9% on est toujours dû en
moyenne à 23 % avec des disparités
importantes entre les propriétaires qui
sont déjà donc qui occupent déjà leur
logement et qui l'ont déjà payé ce taux
est de 11% jusqu'à 46% pour des primes
excédents et 36% pour des locataires
alors la crise elle est aussi très
marquante chez les jeunes ceux qui ont
moins de 30 ans qui représentent
aujourd'hui 11% de la population mais il
part beaucoup plus importante
pratiquement un quart du parc locatif
intermédiaire donc quand on parle
aujourd'hui de la crise du logement
c'est la fois le logement social c'est à
la fois le logement dit intermédiaire
abord abordable c'est à dire pour des
populations qui ne rentrent plus dans le
dans le dans le parc le parcours HLM
logements social mais qui ne peuvent pas
non plus être propriétaire la crise elle
est vraiment très complexe complexe et
multiplions on va essayer dans dans
analyser certains des des aspects
christophe Robert vous avez livré le
premier février dernier un rapport sur
le mal logement et vous pointez
l'insuffisance des réponses publiques on
va on va en parler un peu plus tard dans
ce débat mais d'abord le constat dans
votre rapport quel 28e ce chiffre 4
millions 150 000 personnes mal logées en
France est-ce que vous voyez la
situation s'aggraver sur ce qu'on
appelle le mal logement c'est finalement
c'est assez stable alors ça dépend des
indicateurs parce que le mal logement
s'agrège des situations assez
différentes par exemple parmi les
Maldives il y a les personnes sans
domicile fixe qui peuvent être pour
partie sans abri ou pour partie dans des
hébergements d'urgence par exemple des
hôtels sociaux qui se sont beaucoup
multipliés depuis une dizaine d'années
en nombre
et là on a une dégradation c'est à dire
que le nombre de personnes sans domicile
en France a doublé en 10 ans donc on a
là une
sujet d'inquiétude majeur parce que ça
veut dire qu'on est dépourvu de de
logement si on prend la qualité des
logements depuis l'appel de la baie
pierre en 54 ça considérablement
augmenté vous voyez et puis il y a des
choses qui augmentaient dans le sens
positif à cette amélioré ça c'est
amélioré sensiblement et puis il y a des
choses qui qui ont pu évoluer dans le
temps positivement et qui se dégrade un
certain moment je pense par exemple au
surpeuplement le fait d'avoir un
logement trop petit par rapport à la
taille du ménage c'est quelque chose qui
pendant 30 ans avait considérablement
réduit les phénomènes de surpeuplement
accentués comme le dit l'INSEE et puis
récemment récemment depuis une dizaine
quinzaine d'années avec l'augmentation
des prix des années 2000 en particulier
où on a vu quand même entre 2000 et 2012
les prix de l'immobilier doublés et
pendant ce temps-là les ressources des
ménages ou les salaires ne doublaient
pas et bien là on a vu des gens qui se
tassaient qui se serraient c'est à dire
pour éviter d'aller trop loin de leur
lieu le travail ou du lieu où ils ont
envie d'habiter et bien ils se sont
serrés et puis il y en a d'autres ils
ont pas le choix donc il y a un espèce
de plus en plus de monde finalement
c'est complètement il y a des chiffres
il y a deux chiffres qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est que 4 millions de mal logés
vous l'avez indiqué mais si on regarde
aussi ceux qui sans être mal logés sont
situations de fragilité c'est 12
millions donc effectivement des
populations qui auparavant dans les
années 90 par exemple ne rencontrez pas
difficultés aujourd'hui en rencontre des
personnes qui pouvaient accéder dans les
années 90 à la propriété ne peuvent pas
avec les mêmes ressources en euros
constant on va dire et puis des
phénomènes de concurrence qui se tendent
parce que du coup des logements de
moyenne qualité qui pouvaient par
exemple servir au ménage qui avait des
ressources fragiles et bien sont
utilisés par d'autres aujourd'hui ça
renvoie finalement les plus fragiles
vers des solutions plus déplorables si
vous voulez donc il y a vraiment un
problème l'autre élément majeur c'est
qu'il y a une extension des territoires
qui sont concernés par ces difficultés
de logement liées à la Ferté du logement
les métropoles clairement depuis
longtemps sont en difficulté parce qu'il
y a un décalage entre les ressources
déménagers et les prix pratiquées mais
maintenant les zones frontalières les
zones très touristiques avec une grosse
grosse sollicitation parce que résidence
secondaire montait des plateformes de
location touristique etc on va en parler
évidemment et je vous donne la parole
pas seulement sur ce thème Max Brisson
mais c'est cette crise du logement quand
même dans votre département au Pays
Basque qu'est-ce que ça signifie pour
vous comment vous la ressentez alors moi
je n'ai pas de qui va vous donner mais
j'ai ressenti j'ai des rencontres avec
la population et avec les mères ça se
traduit comment par la disparition
chaque année de location à l'année
transformée en location saisonnière ça
se traduit par des beaux totalement
illégaux 9 mois l'hiver et puis des
personnes qui sont expulsées au mois de
juin ce qui est illégal pour que
l'appartement soit à nouveau mis en
location saisonnière ça se traduit par
des travailleurs des gens désactivent
des gens qui ont un métier et qui
dorment dans la voiture l'été ça se tra
par les gens qui vont se faire se loger
l'été chez les amis ou dans chez des
proches votre disque c'est une précarité
ça se traduit aussi par le fait que des
personnes qui ont des revenus un couple
de fonctionnaires dans une municipalité
ou à l'éducation nationale qui sont
incapables selon loger sur la côte
basque et qui doivent donc se loger de
plus en plus loin avec les conséquences
que l'on connaît en terme de pouvoir
d'achat avec le coût de du carburant par
exemple sans parler du bilan carbone
entre une dégradation
mais est-ce qu'elle est constante cette
dégradation s'aggrave depuis quelque
chose
les plateformes numériques qui ont
certains contribué parce que faire une
location saisonnière c'est très facile
trois clics et on nous sont bien les
mobiles touristiques ne sont pas
d'aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui c'est
très simple très facile ça rapporte
beaucoup ça rapporte de plus en plus et
puis et en plus on est gagnant sur le
plan fiscal ce qui est quand même assez
insupportable autre autre élément par
exemple cet évaporation
des logements à l'année cela se traduit
par le fait que des gens qui sont que la
structure commerciale par exemple des
centres-villes est en train de changer
dans ma bonne ville de Biarritz de plus
en plus difficile de trouver une
épicerie
parce que tout simplement les
restaurants par exemple remplacent ce
type de studio donc on voit bien que les
conséquences sont multiples que c'est le
tissu
urbain le tissu social qui était branlé
et ça se voit c'est facilement et on
essaiera évidemment ensemble de
d'esquisser des solutions maliteux ou
liées intervenir aujourd'hui un prof ou
un employé de banque à Biarritz a du mal
à s'obliger mais est-ce que cette
spéculation touristique si on peut
l'appeler comme ça elle est le fait de
basque si j'ose dire où elle est le fait
de gens qui n'habitent même pas la
région vous n'êtes pas consiste à dire
que quand il y a quelqu'un de
l'extérieur qui achète et bien un masque
et qui vend c'est une c'est une réalité
après qu'est-ce que vous voulez la
possibilité de de réaliser de belles
opérations c'est extrêmement humain le
développement des résidences secondaires
et à dire facilité par des plateformes
numériques puisque on intègre dans le
calcul économique de l'achat d'un bien
le rapport qui n'existait pas aussi
aisément il y a quelques années d'où une
flambée des résidences secondaires et
aussi des locations saisonnières et tout
ceci au départ de la location à l'année
et de l'habitat l'année et attention
parce que dans un territoire comme le
mien ça qu'aujourd'hui est crispation
politique extrêmement inquiétante alors
on va justement en parler dans un court
instant avec Steve Jourdain du rôle des
des plateformes mais je voudrais vous
donner deux chiffres quand même pour
illustrer il y en a beaucoup qui peuvent
illustrer le le les difficultés la crise
du marché du logement là on va parler
des taux de crédit tiens taux de crédit
immobilier ils sont passés de 1% après
3% en un an avec quand même des
conséquences sur la vente de maisons
c'est le pôle habitat de la Fédération
française du bâtiment qui nous donne ces
chiffres moins 31% de vente de maisons
individuelles j'ai bien entendu ce que
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure on a
toujours grosso modo on est toujours en
crise mais est-ce que là c'est c'est pas
la situation précédente qui était
anormale c'est-à-dire des taux très bas
pendant une durée aussi longue une
quinzaine d'années
l'immobilier a été très largement
boostée par des taux d'intérêts anormal
enfin pas normalement bas mais très bas
et des durées d'emprunts qui ont
augmenté donc le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages moyens à exploser on dit à peu
près 80% donc une demande très forte
pour du logement mais il faut bien
distinguer dans le logement
économiquement parlant on peut partir on
peut parler d'un bien qui est j'achète
un logement pour me loger en résidence
principale mais également d'un actif
c'est-à-dire que ça devient une classe
d'actifs comme une action une obligation
et on achète un logement non pas pour le
service qui nous rend personnellement de
ces bergers mais pour le rendement qu'il
procure et on revient sur la question de
des locations saisonnières etc on dit
toujours mais c'est un problème d'offre
il vous offrir davantage oui mais où va
cette offre après dans Comment est
détourné le parc est-ce que c'est un
parc pour permettre aux gens de se loger
et de répondre aux besoins initiaux ou
bien est-ce que c'est un parc qui va
être qui va permettre à des à des
personnes de de de de de se procurer un
revenu un moment locatif il y a aussi
des affection très très forte il faut
expliquer ça aussi parce que il y a une
désinfections très important des
investisseurs dit institutionnels qui
détenaient historiquement de
l'immobilier on a vu tout à l'heure avec
la PHP pour loger des ménages et au
profit comme institut comme investisseur
institutionnel si on doit en citer
quelques-uns parler des grandes
foncières classiques par exemple Société
Foncière Lyonnaise qui était
historiquement une foncière créée sous
la période Haussmann pour héberger rue
de Rivoli par exemple des ménages et qui
mais comme tout entend d'autres ont
plutôt opté pour
pour des raisons de rendement également
pour du bureau et aujourd'hui on voit
que c'est foncières sont en train de se
reposer la question est-ce du bureau en
du logement mais là aussi la question se
pose quel type de logement parce que
encore une fois la clé c'est le
rendement alors je reste et je reviens
parce que vous l'avez évoqué vous aussi
sur cette question des locations
saisonnières Steve Jourdain vous avez
alerté vous devez être juste là vous
pouvez nous rejoindre de nouveau
sur le plateau de sens public donc on va
parler de ces communes où il est de plus
en plus difficile de se loger et on va
faire entrer l'accusé Airbnb la
plateforme de location saisonnière dans
les faits de plus en plus de
propriétaires préfèrent louer
l'horlogements sur une courte période
plutôt qu'à l'année il décide donc et
bien de mettre leur résidence secondaire
sur Airbnb afin de réaliser plus de
profits toutes les régions touristiques
sont concentrées sont concernés par le
phénomène mais on va jeter un oeil sur
la Bretagne la Bretagne ou le phénomène
étant pleine explosion sur les 8
premiers mois de l'année dernière les
plateformes numériques Airbnb et Abritel
ont affiché une progression de plus 36%
en termes de fréquentation par rapport
l'année 2021 chiffre repéré par nos
confrères de Ouest-France alors ça
génère évidemment des taxes de séjour
pour les villes bretonnes et ne sont
plaignent pas mais ça provoque aussi la
colère des habitants qui ont de plus en
plus de difficultés à trouver des
logements abordables dans leur ville
parce que mécaniquement avec la hausse
de la demande sua Airbnb la spéculation
immobilière avant en poupe et les prix
des logements augmentent en flèche
justement et certaines villes ont décidé
de serrer la vis en reste en Bretagne
Saint-Malo a décidé d'appliquer des
quotas de location saisonnière par
quartier la ville limite également le
nombre de logements locatifs de courte
durée par propriétaire ces initiatives
font des petits puisque d'autres
communes également en Bretagne ont aussi
engagé des mesures pour mieux contrôler
Airbnb le problème et bien c'est que ces
décisions sont contestées devant la
justice par des collectifs de
propriétaires ils revendiquent le droit
de faire ce qu'ils veulent de leur bien
et plusieurs manifestations ont eu lieu
cet automne et cet hiver pour justement
demander aux élus de mieux réguler le
marché du logement dans les zones
touristique alors qu'est-ce qui est
prévu qu'est-ce qui ressort une taxe sur
les résidences secondaires qui peut être
décidée par certaines communes le
mécanisme est très encadré les mères
peuvent aujourd'hui surtaxer les
résidences secondaires au titre de la
taxe d'habitation il s'agit des élus
situés dans des agglomérations de plus
de 50 000 habitants classés dans ce
qu'on appelle des zones tendues on parle
d'un peu plus de 11000 communes au total
dans toute la France c'est un outil
intéressant pour les maires car ça
permet de remplir les caisses pour
financer d'investir ça permet aussi
d'investir dans d'autres projets
immobiliers par exemple des logements
sociaux et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle les élus demandent à ce que ce
dispositif soit élargi quelle est la
réponse du gouvernement oui la loi de
finance 2023 prévoit d'élargir le
périmètre d'application de la taxe sur
les résidences secondaires en bref cinq
fois plus de communes vont bientôt
pouvoir utiliser cet outil fiscal il
s'agit de communes où le marché
immobilier jugé tendu ça devrait
concerner des villes situées sur la face
Atlantique ou encore sur la Côte d'Azur
j'utilise le conditionnel car tout le
monde attend maintenant un décret du
gouvernement qui précise les contours de
cette nouvelle taxe des Grecs qui devait
être publiés au mois de février mais
qu'on attend toujours Thomas merci
beaucoup Steve c'est 1136 communes au
total aujourd'hui c'est ça vous aviez
dit 11000 que je préfère je préfère
corriger tout de suite merci beaucoup
Steve pour cette chronique donc on va
continuer de parler de
de l'effet finalement de ces plateformes
je voudrais vous entendre également
là-dessus christophe Robert parce que ce
qu'on décrit quand on décrit des des
gens qui sont finalement des classes
moyennes et qui et qui peuvent pas se
loger normalement l'été c'est une
nouvelle précarité est-ce que c'est un
nouveau mal logement pour vous ça ou
est-ce que vous dites faut quand même
comparer ce qui est comparable alors il
faut il faut avoir en tête que tout est
lié quand vous avez des classements et
inférieure des travailleurs qui
rencontrent des difficultés pour pouvoir
se loger quand vous avez des enfants de
personnes qui habitent dans ces zones là
qui ne trouvent pas chaussures à leurs
pieds vous savez que derrière ceux qui
sont les plus fragiles sont encore moins
bien lotis il y a des effets dominos
exactement c'est fondamental d'avoir ça
en tête c'est pour ça c'est un peu comme
le chômage il faut il faut voilà il y a
la zone grise du chômage et puis il y a
le chômage et donc il faut être très
attentif à ça c'est à dire que nous on
voit les effets dominos que cela produit
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on est en train
de dire vous disiez effectivement est-ce
que c'est la terre c'est naturel les
gens ont envie de se sites on disait
ouais c'est le marché qui fait ça il y a
un moment où la question du logement
c'est pas une question comme les autres
tout le monde a besoin d'un logement
partout sur tout le territoire et à
partir du moment où on identifie ces
dérives là c'est pas du tout idéologique
ce que je vais dire mais il faut
absolument encadrer c'est à dire que en
fait regardez les locations touristiques
elles ont une fiscalité avantageuse il
faut stopper cette fiscalité avantageuse
il faut absolument intervenir pour dire
NON financièrement des gens vont y
trouver un intérêt je parle pas
simplement de louer quelques jours par
semaine par an enfin vous voyez ce que
je veux dire ou quelques semaines c'est
pas de ça dont on parle on parle d'un
business autour de ça et donc à partir
de ce moment là il faut de l'encadrement
c'est comme quand nous avons fait passer
collectivement l'encadrement des loyers
non pas pour bloquer les prix j'ai bien
en tête que les mais de dire il faut
éviter les loyers excessifs il faut
qu'il y ait un regard de la collectivité
c'est tellement important les dégâts
sont tellement importants ça a été dit
sur la question écologique sur la
question sociale du développement des
territoires et c'est très intéressant ce
qui se passait vous disiez dans votre
introduction tout à l'heure que dans des
villes et encore à Bayonne ce week-end
les gens manifestent en disant mais
tension politique autour de ces
questions donc on est voilà c'est pas
une spéculation sur un bien comme les
autres c'est un bien dont tout le monde
a besoin sauf que c'est très difficile
de faire entendre dans ce pays qu'il
faut des régulations donc moi je suis
très satisfait de voir que maintenant il
y a une diversité de d'horizon
politiques d'horizon de territoires
regardons la réalité dans le Cantal
c'est pas le problème ça va être plutôt
la rénovation des logements par exemple
mais on l'a dit les zones frontalières
les zones touristiques les métropoles
les zones attractives économiquement
elles sont aujourd'hui
vraiment en décalage avec les ressources
déménagers il faut faire quelque chose
alors justement on va commencer à
esquisser des solutions Majorie la taxe
sur les résidences secondaires donc là
Steve Jourdain l'évoquait c'est
suffisant comment est-ce que comment les
maires peuvent la glacionner comment ça
se passe
sur mon territoire dans des prédatiques
tous les maires qui peuvent l'actionner
quel que soit leur couleur politique à
l'actionne et alors par rapport à ce
qu'a dit attention c'est pas uniquement
pour faire rentrer de l'argent dans les
caisses c'est un des moyens meilleur
faut beaucoup d'autres pour lutter
contre une propagation spéculative des
résidences secondaires et des locations
saisonnières il s'agit pas de remettre
en cause les résidences secondaires ou
de remettre en cause les locations de
Moby touristiques c'est la dimension
spéculative qui est extrêmement
dangereuse et qui a cet effet domino
dont vous parlait les mères il constate
aussi que ça détruit le tissu
urbain le tissu social de la commune que
ça un effet domino que ça crée des
embouteillages monstrueux au
centre-ville parce que les gens se
logent de plus en plus et puis il y a
des gens qui dorment dans la rue qui
dorment dans les voitures les effets
sociaux sont considérables donc
simplement pour des dire que les mères
sont alertés sur le sujet pas uniquement
avec une idée simplement de faire entrer
dans genre dans les caisses honnêtement
c'est bien secondaire par rapport aux
préoccupations aujourd'hui centre-ville
avec les locations saisonnières
excusez-moi de vous dire c'est le bazar
parce que pour lui dire très simplement
parce que notre atelier son métier c'est
de réguler ces deux gérer c'est de
calmer les jeunes qui font un peu de
bruit on a des immeubles qui ne sont pas
faits aujourd'hui pour être transformés
en hôtel et excusez-moi de dire aussi
cela se fait aux dépens de l'hôtellerie
traditionnelle cela fait aux déport de
celles et ceux qui en ont fait
profession qui paient leur taxe de
séjour qui peut leurs impôts et à qui on
impose des règles chaque jour ou chaque
année peut-être souvent plus draconienne
alors qu'on a des locations saisonnières
qui échappent alors oui la taxe est une
solution mais elle a trouvé ses effets
je suis partisan aussi nous avions voté
un amendement dans ce sens au Sénat de
décorer la taxe foncière la foncière
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas
l'augmenter pour les locations pour les
résidences secondaires si vous de
l'augmentez pas pour les résidences
principales la décorrélation par exemple
avec une fourchette de sénateur bas
avait proposé 20% pour que le vote du
Sénat se fasse très largement certes
deux taxes foncières dans la même
commune c'est ça
fiscales on ne peut pas augmenter les un
taux uniquement ça augmente les autres
moi je souhaite qu'on puisse décorer les
de manière à des faits à ce que les
propriétaires
qui résident ne soient pas taxé aussi
fortement que les propriétés que les
résidences solidaires et voyez bien je
suis élu du groupe les républicains que
ce genre de position aujourd'hui touche
des élus de toute sensibilité politique
parce que la crise est devenue d'acuité
extrêmement forte et dans une région
comme la mienne elle crée des
crispations politiques qui sont
inquiétantes c'est du véritablement que
nous avons dans les mers est-ce que vous
décriviez tout à l'heure c'est la qu'on
a tous vécu effectivement en trois clics
on peut on peut trouver ou louer un
logement une grille on le soupçonnait
pas ça à quel point l'irruption de ces
plateformes du type Airbnb à changer
peut-être même la nature du marché de
l'immobilier ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que on achète plus
un logement pour se loger on achète
peut-être aussi pour pour rentabiliser
quoi pour pouvoir acheter ce logement il
faut pouvoir il faut avoir les
conditions donc financières notamment et
c'est cette baisse des taux d'intérêt
qui a permis ce développement de de
faire tout simplement fonctionner ce
qu'on appelle l'effet de levier
c'est-à-dire vous emprunter un taux FAI
pour pouvoir investir dans un actif qui
est va rapporter davantage donc
aujourd'hui la question d'augmentation
des taux d'intérêts peut peut-être être
un frein à ce à ce mécanisme là mais oui
bien sûr toutes les mais c'est la même
chose pour les bureaux aussi donc on a
cette ces plateformes qui liquide enfin
qui rendent les actifs beaucoup plus
liquides voilà mais au départ il faut
quand même bien pouvoir se permettre
d'acheter un logement pour ça alors on a
on a évoqué vous avez évoqué la
situation de ces habitants notamment
dans les régions touristiques qui
parfois sont à la rue pendant une
période de l'année tenez écoutez c'était
lors d'une manifestation encore dans
votre région c'était à Bayonne c'est en
juin dernier
manifestation pour dénoncer la
suspension par la justice administrative
d'une réglementation locale destinée à
freiner l'expansion alors là on est sur
les meublés touristiques écoutez cette
porte-parole de l'association biSy
à travers les différentes associations
et par les différents témoignages qui
montent de plus en plus qui a des gens
qui ont un emploi mais qui tombent dans
la voiture ou qui sont obligés de de ou
qui vont dans un camping ou qui
retournent chez les parents ou qui sont
carrément obligés de refuser l'emploi il
y a une vraie crise
c'est aussi un thème de tension
politique de récupération par certains
mouvements cette dame fait écho une
délibération de la communauté
d'agglomération Pays Basque qui avait
fait été rejeté par la justice
administrative depuis une nouvelle
délibération a été prise on a tenu
compte de ce qu'adieu de juge
administratif et depuis le premier avril
dans mon territoire au Pays Basque dans
les zones tendues pour tout bien mis en
location saisonnière il y aura
obligation de mettre un bien en location
à l'année c'est la compensation un
coureur c'est une mesure drastique mais
qu'est-ce qu'on est oui parce que tous
les propriétés tous les propriétaires
ont pas de bien quoi
là j'imagine la mesure est drastique
j'en conviens mais c'est aussi le
résultat d'une spéculation qui s'est
développée sans limite et
malheureusement comme si souvent le cas
dans d'autres pays on a trop tardé on
n'a pas voulu gérer la question et donc
c'est les braves gens ce qui en effet un
pied qui met en location ou qui de la
location saisonnière pour une résidence
secondaire pour pour
limiter les frais de cette résidence
secondaire qui sont aujourd'hui touchés
mais c'est la conséquence d'un effet
spéculatif qu'on a laissé faire trop tôt
et Dieu sait si les élus du territoire
les élus du Pays Basque que je
représente ici mais aussi de Bretagne de
la Côte d'Azur ont tiré la sonnette
d'alarme depuis très longtemps mais je
me demande si le gouvernement écoute
encore puisque l'ensemble des amandes de
morts qui ont été votés à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat sur la symétrie
fiscale sur le fait qu'il est beaucoup
plus avantageux de louer de manière
saisonnière qu'à l'année avec des
abattements qui sont exorbitants et bien
toute cette asymétrie fiscale n'a pas
été réglé sur dans le cadre du projet de
loi de finance avec le 49-3 tous les
apports du Sénat par exemple ont été
balayés lors du passage gold of 3 donc
on nous dit prise de conscience ça urge
alors justement on va parler de l'action
du gouvernement et Mathieu pour
commencer pour ouvrir ce chapitre vous
êtes intéressé au profil du ministre du
Logement oui qui connaît Olivier Klein
nommé ministre du Logement le 4 juillet
2022 dans le second gouvernement
d'isabeth borne le portefeuille du
logement on n'avait pas été attribué
dans la première mouture Olivier Klein
fait partie de ces ministres qui sont la
fois finisseur de leur portefeuille mais
qui peine à passer le mur du son un peu
comme l'Enseigneur gentiliste François
Brown à la santé ou l'enseignant Papen
DIY à l'éducation il déroute les acteurs
de son secteur par sa grande discrétion
l'exécutif misait pourtant beaucoup sur
ce qui était une forme de prise de
guerre Olivier Klein il vient des rangs
de la gauche il a été longtemps
communiste jusqu'en 2002 puis ensuite au
Parti socialiste c'est l'ancien maire de
Clichy-sous-Bois la ville où il a grandi
donc c'est donc un élu de terrain qui
connaît parfaitement pour y avoir été
confronté les problématiques de
l'habitat en général et du mal logement
en particulier puis ça a été les anciens
présidents de la rue c'est donc j'ai un
élu de terrain un homme de conviction et
qui connaît quand même son dossier alors
d'où vient la d'où viennent les
difficultés alors il y a peut-être un
problème personnel d'Olivier Klein on
n'est pas pas forcément du statut des
Lucas la ministre national facilement il
faudra peut-être lui laisser un temps
d'adaptation et puis aussi un problème
j'allais dire du gouvernement et
peut-être du président parce que le
logement n'a jamais fait partie des
priorités affichées du macronisme depuis
le début et qui a préféré s'attaquer aux
inégalités par le fond de l'emploi et de
la lutte contre le chômage mais jamais
par la politique du logement la
politique de juin elle a connu des
débuts vous souvenez symboliques
difficiles avec cette fameuse baisse de
des européennes et puis il y a eu des
lois il y a eu des budgets en hausse
comme celui parce que Olivier Klein il a
foi ministre de la Ville et ministre de
du logement il a eu un budget en hausse
à l'automne dernier pour son ministère
mais le choc d'offre sonner c'était ce
mot qui avait promis Emmanuel Macron en
2017 et ben n'a jamais eu lieu en
matière de logement le logement a été
considéré sous son angle fiscal avec la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation il
est considéré aujourd'hui sous son angle
écologique j'allais dire avec toute la
transformation de la rénovation
énergétique mais pas grand chose d'autre
et même si je disais il y a eu des lois
il y a une loi qui s'appelait la loi
Elan en 2018 même si sur le point de vue
logement d'urgence se porte-parole du
gouvernement se félicitait le mois
dernier que la France n'est jamais
autant compté de place d'urgence c'était
un record la promesse d'Emmanuel Macron
qui était quand même en 2017 de ne plus
voir personne dans la rue avant la fin
de l'année évidemment ça ça a été tenu
donc Olivier Klein peut-il inverser la
donne il faut que sans doute qu'ils
prennent de l'ampleur mais il faut se
des moyens pour des moyens il en a un
peu mais pas suffisamment on le sait
bien et puis il faut une vision et c'est
surtout ça qui manque et sans compter
que le logement c'est un chantier de
long terme politique du temps long et
que les mal logés sont chaque année plus
nombreux donc on est dans le temps court
et donc c'est ce hiatus qui se pose à
tous les ministres du logement mais
qu'il a devient de plus en plus
préoccupant christophe Robert je reviens
à votre rapport annuel très critique sur
la faiblesse de des réponses publiques
au mal logement pourquoi vous êtes à ce
point critique pour les raisons qui
viennent d'être évoquées c'est à dire
que le logement quand on regarde bien
alors tout ce que l'on vient de dire
alors l'importance de cette question du
logement en réalité
quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé dans
le premier quinquennat effectivement
l'objectif d'Emmanuel Macron c'était un
choc d'offre qui devait faire baisser
les prix on a une baisse de production
de logement toute catégories confondues
et une baisse de production de logements
sociaux
il y a une augmentation des places
d'hébergement d'urgence qui sont pas
satisfaisantes pour les gens même s'il
faut les ouvrir quand les gens sont la
rue mais pas non plus satisfaisante pour
les finances publiques parce que c'est
du temporaire et c'est pas ça dont les
gens ont besoin en réalité quand on
regarde ce qui s'est passé dans le
premier quinquennat il y a eu 15
milliards d'économies du budget de
l'État dédié au logement ce qui fait que
c'est un des principales contributeurs
de la baisse des dépenses publiques donc
c'est un choix c'est passé par quoi les
appels alors tout le monde a en tête les
5 euros mais on a supprimé la PL
accession à la propriété on n'a pas
indexé sur le niveau de vie de
l'inflation pour faire vite donc il y a
eu ensuite une ponction de 1 milliard 3
d'euros sur les bailleurs sociaux par an
qui a été reconduite dans le budget
première année du deuxième quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron donc qu'est-ce qu'on
est en train de dire
c'est que finalement c'est pas considéré
comme une politique du logement en
dehors de la baisse de dépenses
budgétaire alors il y a des efforts qui
sont faits sur l'hébergement d'urgence
parce que forcément dans un contexte
comme celui que nous sommes en train de
décrire depuis une demi-heure ça crée
des tensions et ça crée une exclusion
mais majeur c'est à dire voir des
personnes à la rue dans un pays riche
quand même comme le nôtre c'est quelque
chose d'insupportable et donc on rajoute
des places d'hébergement d'urgence il y
avait un point positif dans le premier
quinquennat Emmanuel Macron qu'on avait
rencontré à l'occasion de la publication
du rapport de la fondation en 2016 a dit
moi ça m'intéresse votre politique par
rapport aux personnes sans domicile du
logement d'abord justement l'idée étant
d'inverser la logique on arrête les
hébergements d'urgence et les hôtels
sociaux pour offrir une solution de
logement accompagné pour des personnes
qui auraient besoin d'être accompagnées
pour les personnes fragiles en disant
c'est comme ça qu'on va les aider à
reprendre trouver un boulot à se soigner
à se reposer avoir une vie sociale cet
axe là a été mobilisé pendant 5 ans avec
une un plan quinquennal pour le logement
d'abord qui produit des effets
intéressants dans le changement de
posture sauf que il pas eu une montée en
puissance de ses réponses là suffisantes
pour inverser la tendance et
parallèlement comme on a coupé dans les
deux leviers de la protection sociale
dans le domaine du logement que sont les
APL et le logement social d'un côté vous
avez cette politique du logement d'abord
qui produit des effets vertueux mais
quantitativement insuffisante et de
l'autre vous avez une fragilité des
outils de protection dans le domaine du
logement donc ça passe pas donc là si on
voulait changer s'il fallait faire vite
pour expliquer ce que nous avons en tête
à la Fondation c'est d'accélérer le
logement d'abord d'augmenter la
production de logements là où il y en a
des là où il y a des besoins et puis de
réguler les marchés là où c'est trop
trop difficile comme on vient de
l'indiquer mais alors sur la question
justement de la construction produire
plus de logements logements neuf
logements sociaux c'est pas si simple
écoutez ce qu'on dit le président du
Medef il tire la sonnette d'alarme sur
ce point oui je signale quand même un
problème de logement on va au devant
c'est une bombe à retardement la
construction neuve donc logement neuf
est en train de ralentir à toute vitesse
l'année 23 pas de bonne et l'année 24
catastrophe puisque c'est il y a des
pannes construire à délivrer etc et ça
c'est un problème qui va très au-delà
des emprises de construction
on construit en ce moment moins où il y
a une espèce de spirale négative quand
même
expliquer que la France n'est pas en si
mauvais état par rapport à d'autres pays
et notamment en Europe on construit
plutôt bien et même on fait partie des
pays où la production de logements
partaient d'habitants et bien plus
importantes donc faut quand même
recycler le contenu on est en train il y
a un coup de frein là qui est
problématique qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors parce que également mais également
le bâtiment est un secteur qui est
fortement contributeur au PIB la
croissance économique on dit l'âge qu'on
le bâtiment va tout va bon aujourd'hui
on sait aussi que le bâtiment est le
premier émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
première émetteur également de déchets
donc on ne peut plus produire comme on
l'a fait jusqu'à présent depuis 50 ans
de manière quantitative il faut
aujourd'hui réfléchir sur la production
de produire plutôt qualitativement
plutôt que quantitativement et surtout
de rénover parce qu'il y a déjà du bâti
les bâtiments existent le problème c'est
que la plupart de ces bâtiments sont
vétustes ou sont des passoires
thermiques ou sont pas adaptés à la
population qui est également vie de plus
en plus et qui a des besoins différents
donc aujourd'hui c'est plus trop le
débat de construire davantage que de
construire différemment et de rénover et
de lancer le secteur de la construction
par la rénovation votre avis là-dessus
il faut pas choisir c'est pas la preuve
pour Londres de mon point de vue c'est à
dire qu'il faut absolument rénover les
5,4 millions de passoires thermiques il
faut aider et il y a eu des efforts qui
ont été faits avec ma prime rénove vous
le disiez tout à l'heure les dispositifs
qui ont été mis en place il y a des
limites parce que elles sont pas assez
performantes donc il y a un travail à
faire et les ménages modestes et pauvres
ne peuvent pas mener ces rénovations
parce qu'il faut rajouter à ces aides
publiques des montants trop importants
enfin il s'est pas parce que il faut
rénover le parc qu'il faut pas produire
dans un certain nombre de territoires ça
c'est la première chose par contre mais
est-ce qu'on peut le faire parce que il
peut y avoir une contraction entre les
enjeux de de transformation
environnementale et et par exemple la
loi contre l'artificialisation du sol
tenir les deux bouts nous n'avons pas
d'autre choix industriels pour les pour
les réhabiliter
l'histoire aux gens dans un territoire
comme le mien si on ne produit pas de
logement et du logement neuf la crise du
logement va s'amplifier donc le droit au
logement est aussi un droit tout aussi
important que le droit à lutter contre
le régional climatique
mais ancré dans la tête de gens qu'on va
sortir d'un kidorment sans produire plus
de logement de mon point de vue c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement grave parce
que on voit très bien ce qui est en
train de se passer au nom du Zéro
artificiel on est dès que vous avez un
programme de logement social Vous avez
tous les recours possibles imaginables
on trouve toujours de bonnes raisons
pour dire que le logement social c'est
mieux chez le voisin au nom des grands
principes de la lutte contre les chevaux
climatiques alors là moi dans mon
territoire des gens qui sont devenus des
porteurs de cette thèse sur le zéro
artificielle
chez eux en général c'est qu'il y a un
programme de logement social à côté de
chez eux ça devient une partie les
recours se multiplient excusez-moi mais
il y a une politique d'urgence sociale
dans le quinquennat précédent ça a été
de faire les poches des bailleurs
sociaux aujourd'hui les bailleurs
sociaux n'ont plus assez de fonds
propres
compte tenu de la hausse des coûts de
construction pour assurer le modèle
économique de la production du logement
social dans mon département le principal
bailleur social l'Office 64 de l'habitat
produit actuellement un produit à
l'année dernière 300 logements 150 en
locatif social il en produisait 500 il y
a 5 ans 500 et 150 il a produit 3 ans
parce qu'il y a 150 BRS des des beaux
réels et solidaires qui permet
l'acquisition sociale à la propriété ce
qui est d'ailleurs une excellent outil
pour permettre au classement moyenne de
poids se loger et voyez on est passé de
150 locatifs sociaux de 500 à 150 dans
un début ça c'est un exemple très
concret qui montre bien intéressant du
logement en terme de production nouvelle
on va continuer de parler de voilà de de
double objectif on va dire
transformation environnementale et et en
jeu de construction mais peut-être une
question plus conjoncturelle les
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
c'est-à-dire que on a vu le secteur du
bâtiment avoir des difficultés à trouver
des matériaux des matériaux de plus en
plus chers etc de renoncer à certains
chantiers à cause de ça est-ce que c'est
réglé ou pas
de construction continue non c'est pas
réglé la guerre Ukraine je pense que le
prix du pétrole va même augmenter on le
sait depuis 24 heures
que ce soit au niveau des coûts de des
taux d'intérêt notamment des frais
financiers pour les constructeurs pour
les promoteurs que la rareté du foncier
parce que le foncier c'est quand même
également pratiquement 30% voire 50%
parfois de certaines opérations
immobilières le foncier par l'arté par
la pénurie mais également parce que la
hausse des prix mobiliers qu'on a pu
observer jusqu'à présent fait par un
mécanisme de compte à rebours c'est un
peu l'oeuf et la poule mais c'est en
fait le prix de l'immobilier qui fait
monter le prix du foncier parce que une
fois qu'on a vendu à tel prix du mètre
carré c'est très difficile pour un
ménage pour quiconque d'ailleurs
d'accepter que son prix baisse
brutalement donc là il y a vraiment un
phénomène ce qu'on appelle de cliquer
les prix ne baissent pas alors qu'ils
montent de manière exponentielle donc
oui les conditions de construction se
deviennent vraiment difficiles pour
construire d'où l'importance de
privilégier aujourd'hui des nouvelles
façons de construire donc des circuits
courts notamment également des matériaux
qui sont réutilisation des matériaux des
circuits sourds ce qu'on appelle
l'économie les déchets d'un chantier
comme une ressource également sur cette
question également des ressources on est
aujourd'hui dans un nouveau paradigme
qui est celui de la rareté des
ressources arceaux financière ressources
de construction mais également de l'eau
parce que dans certains départements
notamment le Var par exemple ou l'Ariège
des permis de construire sont bloqués
parce que justement il y a des problèmes
d'approvisionnement de l'eau pour ces
résidences donc là aussi on se rend
compte qu'on est en train de toucher du
doigt un problème à venir si on
construit massivement encore une fois et
qu'on ne fait pas très attention à la
façon dont on répartir
et également un problème avec ce solde
migratoire positif du télétravail qui
fait que des gens
migrent de Paris ou de la région
parisienne pour aller vers des cieux
plus clément il y a également ce
problème pour l'agriculture de la manque
des ressources naturelles donc le
foncier je veux dire il est pas
constructible à n'importe quel prix
allez je reprends la main parce que je
voudrais parler pour terminer il nous
reste un peu moins de 5 minutes de la
conséquence de la loi sur les passoires
thermiques vous savez que il y a une
pression et là encore le la cause énorme
il s'agit il s'agit de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique 700 000
logements classés G sont retirés du
marché en 2025 en 2030 sur les logements
classés F en 2035 les logements classés
eux d'ici 2035 si mes chiffres sont bons
ça fait 7 millions de logements
concernés sur les 32 millions de
résidences principales que contre la
France est-ce que alors Christopher a un
double aspect les premières victimes de
c'est pasteur thermique ce sont ceux qui
ce qui logent et donc c'est très bien de
voir les rénover sauf qu'il y a beaucoup
de propriétaires qui soit n'auront pas
la volonté soit n'auront pas les moyens
de rénover ils vont arrêter de les louer
donc vous voyez ce que je veux dire
est-ce que est-ce que la la mesure va
pas filer finalement mettre des gens à
la rue
non je pense que ça vient d'être dit on
peut plus faire comme avant donc à
partir de ce moment là il faut
absolument engager la transformation du
parc pour faire des économies d'énergie
d'une part parce que c'est un des
principales émetteurs avec ce gaz a été
super ça a été dit et puis parce que
c'est ce qui permettra de faire baisser
la facture d'un certain nombre de
ménages donc c'est vertueux donc la loi
énergique vous faites référence qui
monte en puissance
jusqu'en 2035 c'est à dire depuis le 1er
janvier dernier jusqu'en 2035 justement
elle vise à pouvoir il y a aussi des
moyens de pas de contourner mais
d'intégrer des contraintes donc je vais
pas rentrer dans le détail mais ce que
je veux dire mais encore une fois que la
question c'est une partie de ces 7
millions de logements sont retirés du
marché
du marché comme ça voilà c'est ça c'est
ça l'élément de réponse en revanche là
où je partage votre analyse ou question
c'est de dire
on ne peut pas on est obligé de passer
par des interdictions à un moment ou un
autre on le sait partout dans le monde
on sait que si jamais il n'y a pas des
contraintes on pourra pas faire évoluer
il faut le faire de manière progressive
mais surtout accompagner accompagné
c'est à dire c'est comme tout les
chantiers qui sont devant nous c'est
vrai pour les véhicules thermiques c'est
vrai pour le zéro artificialisation net
versus la nécessité de construire si on
intègre pas la dimension sociale la
dimension accompagnement donc qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que quand
vous êtes propriétaire bailleur donc
vous louez un logement il est normal de
le mettre aux normes électriques ou de
normes thermiques désormais avec ses
cliquets qu'on vient d'évoquer en
revanche il se peut qu'un certain nombre
de personnes ne puisse pas le faire et
c'est là où il faut impérativement que
la société mette les moyens pour
accompagner les ménages ce qui a déjà
commencé à être fait c'est pas suffisant
le ministre du Logement nous a confié un
CNR logement un conseil national de la
refondation que je coanime avec
Véronique bedac direct générale de
Nexity on avait trois groupes de travail
on espère que le gouvernement va se
saisir de nos propositions dont un était
justement là-dessus comment on considie
ces deux objectifs fondamentaux il faut
accompagner et différencier oui il faut
accompagner mais surtout les territoires
il y a pas eu de construction massive
les territoires ruraux ils disent ils
n'ont pas artificialisé les soldes et la
sobriété française ils devront la porter
au moment où peut-être il y a des gens
qui sont prêts à s'installer avec le
télétravail en zone rural donc ils ne
comprennent pas donc la loi climat
résidence à mon avis a besoin en tous
les cas de plus de différenciation quand
on passe en thermique dont vous avez
parlé en 30 secondes en moyenne de
détourner aujourd'hui il est passoire
les règles ne sont pas sur Internet
c'est faire de la location saisonnière
parce que dans d'autres
vous êtes soumis aux règles si vous
louez de manière vous n'êtes pas là
c'est vraiment absurde encore une une
évaluation et une évolution qu'on espère
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous dis à
demain et je vous donne votre prochain
rendez-vous politique sur notre antenne
c'est le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Pap Ndiaye qui sera l'invité
Dorian Mancini il sera 8h du matin c'est
le moment là salut bonne soirée
[Musique]